this is the Lord Howe Island stick  insect and this species did be  impossible they came back from  extinction the Lord Howe Island stick  insect is the largest flightless stick  insect and can grow up to four inches in  length that's almost the length of an  adult humans hand it is affectionately  nicknamed the tree lobster the land  lobster and even the walking sausage  Lord Howe Island stick insects were once  so common on Lord Howe Island that they  were used as bait by fishermen then a  British supply ship crashed on the  island in 1918 accidentally introducing  rats who ate the insects by 1960 they  were declared extinct then in 2001  Australian scientists discovered a tiny  population hidden on a small volcanic  island nearby thanks to a breeding  program at Melbourne Zoo they have been  able to save and repopulate the species  this is the Lord Howe Island stick  insect